yeah thank you griffin aisha for more on
the situation at the southern border
we're joined by former acting director
of ice and fox news contributor tom
homan tom thank you so much for being
here appreciate it as always let's start
off with a little-known plan that has
just been unveiled by the biden
administration is now enacted that is
now allowing asylum officers on the
border to grant asylum to certain people
that they deem eligible that have um uh
you know that feel that fear for their
life if they think that it's credible
these asylum officers on the border can
now grant asylum and they no longer have
to go to an immigration judge or court
the administration says this is an
opportunity to really fight against the
backlog some 1.7 million people who are
waiting for their court cases to be
adjudicated what is your response tom to
this latest plan this that has been
unveiled over the last four days uh to
try to swiftly grant asylum well once
again administration is lying look the
secretary goes out and say the trump
ministry they inherited a dismantled
immigration system no one's dismantled
the immigration system more than the
bite administration the president signed
90 executive orders basically abolishing
all the policies we created under
president trump to give us the most
secure border in my lifetime and this
new policy is just the latest example of
them ignoring federal statute ignoring
the laws that are enacted by congress
and how asylum process is supposed to
work so rather than seeing an
independent
judge who makes the determination based
on the facts of the case in the law
they're going to send them to a cis
employee who works for the
administration who is not independent so
here's here's what here's the truth
behind this the administration knows
that nine out of 10 central americans
who claim asylum at the border never get
relief from u.s courts they either don't
show up in court or they don't qualify
but they don't like those numbers they
don't like 90 percent they don't get
ordered to be removed they want those
numbers to increase so how they do that
they change the silent process they
already change the rules while it
qualifies for asylum supposed to be fear
and persecution from your home
government because race religion
political affiliation now they want to
ask is domestic violence involved is
there gang violence in the area they're
adding all these other issues so more
people can qualify then instead of
putting in front of an independent judge
and have an ice attorney there to to to
ask questions they're going to have an
employee
rubber stamp applications to increase
that 90 to greatly decrease in 90 denial
rate that's that's the endgame error
yeah so the administration says that the
these asylum officers on the border will
not be able to deny uh somebody asylum
but if they believe that that's credible
enough they can accept the asylum
process fast track those cases and these
other people that would be denied would
somehow be fast-tracked in the court
system we'll see let's look at these
numbers
that's a great point so they'll give
them a second shot at the apple right so
either they get awarded but if it's no
then they can see a judge and take a
second shot at it this administration
can say what they want but the facts are
the facts are out there for people to
see
yeah the texas attorney general ken
paxton has filed a lawsuit we'll see
where that goes we'll look at the
numbers this fiscal year compared to
last fiscal year you can see 1.2 pretty
much 1.3 million border encounters so
far this fiscal year up 73 percent
almost double what we saw last year and
last year was a record
what do you make of the messaging
from this administration and what do you
think is going to happen over the next
three or four months title 42 still in
place but with this new messaging how do
you think that's going to affect things
well their messaging means nothing they
can say don't come now it's not time to
come but they keep passing policies like
the asylum rule saying ice can't arrest
somebody for simply being here illegally
when they shut down detention they go
back to catch and release when they make
all these promises people are going to
come the most vulnerable people are
going to put themselves in the hands of
colonel cartels that come to united
states and something griff mentioned i
want a foot stomp on they say the biden
policies are so much more humane than
trump's policies more migrants have died
on u.s soil under first year joe biden
than any year in my career so where's
the aoc's where's the congressman castro
ran to the border when a child died
under the trump administration but now
you have record migrants dying on u.s
soil and no one's no one's saying
anything about about the chaos down
there and add to that the over a hundred
thousand opioid overdose deaths of
opioids coming across the border because
border patrol is no longer on the line
70 of them are off the line dealing with
this crisis where are all the people
that were concerned about life that not
just the migrants of u.s citizens this
administration's policies are creating a
lot more debt than we ever saw during
any other administration i've worked for
and i've worked for six tom
tom last last question and quickly here
sorry because running out of time but i
wanted to ask you remain in mexico
policy under the trump administration
title 42 all of these seem to be
temporary policies and fixes it's been
part of the frustration on people of the
border do you believe that the remaining
mexico policy which is
now in the hands of the supreme court
should that policy
be the law of the land permanently is
that the fix here for asylum cases
people should wait in mexico until their
asylum case is adjudicated knowing that
ninety percent don't qualify based on
court data knowing that less than six
percent leave when ordered removed by
judge it's the best case scenario it's
the game changer it helps secure the
border i helped i i followed affidavit
with texas in that lawsuit we won the
lawsuit i hope the supreme court backs
up on it because it helps secure the
border which saves lives
tom holman former ice director and fox
news contributor appreciate you as
always thank you aisha
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight